but first the latest on our top story
confusion and controversy on immigration
a senior Trump administration official
tells CBS News that as of last night
over 500 children in custody of Customs
and Border Protection were reunited with
their parents but hundreds more remain
in the government's custody at the White
House Friday the president hosted
parents of Americans who were killed by
illegal immigrants these are the
American citizens permanently separated
from their loved ones they're not
separated for a day or two days they are
permanently separated because they were
killed by criminal illegal aliens
earlier on Friday the president
apparently upended Republican efforts to
pass an immigration bill mr. Trump
tweeted quote Republicans should stop
wasting their time on immigration until
after we elect more senators and
Congress men and women in November
this week President Trump issued an
executive order reversing his
administration's policy of separating
migrant children from their parents when
they attempt to enter the US illegally
the decision came after a huge public
outcry in its cover story this week Time
magazine called the debate over the
policy nothing less than a referendum on
core American values we're joined by the
story's author time editor-at-large Carl
Vick Carl good morning morning Carl the
president's stance on immigration has
been very public it's been a tenant of
his campaign and his presidency
how did tolerance turn into this massive
public crisis there seem to be two
things going on with the policy which
took which the administration was sort
of slow to reveal into own there was a
surge of course sort of a seasonal surge
in in crossings and attempted crossings
and I think they wanted to crackdown on
that zero tolerance meant everybody gets
prosecuted it also meant they're gonna
take kids away which is something that
the US hadn't done before so I think
they were really trying to send a signal
like come to America you're gonna lose
your children pretty brutal the other
thing I think they were trying to do is
when Trump first acknowledged this
policy it was
he blamed it on the Democrats he said it
says horrible policy
I wish the Democrats would do something
so he seemed to be wanting to force a
decision a vote basically trying to get
Congress to address immigration so that
he could he could make a play to get his
wall which has been you know here an
hour all this and we're gonna build this
big beautiful wall hasn't been able to
get it through Congress so at this point
I mean you have the president now
backtracking essentially on the
separation of families but at the same
time going forward and making a play
about about illegal immigration
yesterday in which he was taking illegal
immigrants you know cause crime in the
country he's trying is he it looks like
he's trying to make this an issue going
into the fall election and and if so can
he make it except a successful one do
you think it's it's really not playing
his way so far is it I mean this is this
has been his issue and now it's become I
think an issue that the Democrats see is
going to cut their way in the fall in in
in the midterms it's you know they're
calling it well nobody's calling it just
Katrina but it's like it's it's his
biggest black eye so far in and it's on
his core issue it has been referenced as
his version of Katrina you mentioned the
core issue he seldom goes against his
base yet with at least his executive
order with his order to not have the
separations it did go against his base
does that even have an impact he kept
his base you know you could still hear
people and and radio talk show hosts
parroting his talking points but he was
losing everybody else and we're gonna be
coming out of primary season the fall
elections will be general the elections
and you need the independence and and
Republican women and people who were
horrified by this to be you know able to
vote for you in the meantime there's
still enormous confusion at the border
I mean how close do you think is is this
issue being to at least to settle down
somewhat that's a very good question I
think as long as since it's become a
story of individuals and children and
and and the the the suffering of of you
know these kids as long as you have a
one or two
so we're right now we're still talking
about thousands you know who are not
with their parents it's gonna be people
so gonna be covering it you hope but we
do lose focus we were talking about the
Flint water crisis in the first hour and
people have lost focus and that involved
children as well that's a good question
Carl Vick thank you so much for being
with us this morning pleasure